apple's m1 max have been absolutely
great
exceeding our expectations in many
different ways
as well as being the main reason for
apple seeing a huge spike in max
sales last quarter but about a month ago
a new issue arose that was big enough to
get some people
to avoid buying an m1 mac altogether
longhorn and apple developer
tweeted out some stats from its m1 max
ssd usage
showing that it was already using one
percent of the lifespan
in just over two months and the culprit
was of course
ssd ram swapping even though he had a 16
gig ram model
shortly after that more and more users
shared the stats from their m1 mac ssd
drives
some even showing 10 usage after
only a couple months which is obviously
way too much
and to make matters worse apple solders
their ssds onto the logic board
so you can't replace it yourself so in
this video
i'm going to discuss ssd swapping on m1
max
and if it's actually a legitimate
concern for people
looking to buy a new mac but first i
want to dig
deep into explaining exactly what ssd
swapping is and how it works
so that you can understand the full
picture so let's get right into it when
you have an app or program open on your
computer
the system stores temporary data that
the app needs to run
onto the ram which stands for random
access
memory which is basically just like a
storage drive
except that it has extremely fast
transfer speeds
compared to a regular ssd storage drive
so as you interact with the app
the system is constantly writing reading
and
updating the ram file for that app until
you finally
close it at that point the data file for
the app is erased
off of the ram storage freeing up more
space
for other apps now let's say you have
multiple apps open
and you're beginning to use quite a lot
of your total ram the system
really doesn't want you to run out of
ram because if it does
apps will begin to crash and bug out
which is something that apple
absolutely cannot have happen because it
basically ruins the reliability
of the mac to avoid this from happening
the system will look at
all of the apps that are currently using
the ram and then find the ones
that are of a lower priority for example
it could be an app that doesn't require
very much performance
like the mail or calendar app or
something simple like that
or it could be an app that you have open
in the background but you're not really
using it at that time
the system then takes that app's ram
file and swaps it
over to the actual ssd drive the same
drive that you store
all of your photos and files on this
ultimately makes sure that there is
always
free high-speed ram ready to go in case
the system needs it
so that it can maintain a consistent
level of performance
without any reliability issues this is
basically what everyone is referring to
as ssd swap usage now here's where the
real problem comes in
solid state drives or ssds have a
specific
lifespan that is measured by the amount
of data that is written
to the drive so the more data you write
to it
the more wear on the ssd and the sooner
that the ssd
will eventually fail for example this
sabrine
m.2 ssd has a lifespan of around 380
terabytes written
so when you hit that point the ssd may
start to fail
the whole issue with ssd swapping is
that if your system is constantly
writing data files
onto the ssd instead of the ram like it
should be doing
this will essentially add extra wear to
the ssd
and make it reach that end of life
terabytes written level
sooner than expected now before you get
mad at apple for doing this
don't because basically every operating
system does this
yes windows does it and yes linux does
it as well
simply for the fact that it actually
works and
greatly helps the system maintain strong
levels of performance
without glitches or hiccups in fact
colonel manager andrew morton
says that he runs his machines with full
swap usage
because he wants to leave the dedicated
memory for something useful
instead of it being wasted on common
apps so it basically points to ssd swap
being a normal part of a functioning
modern computer
but the story doesn't end there because
this ssd swap issue
only really came up when apple released
their m1 max
so if you're wondering what's unique
about the m1 chip let me
explain the new m1 chip uses a unified
memory architecture
which greatly reduces latency between
components
which helps improve performance and i
personally think it's a big part of why
the m1 chip
has been so impressive recently we
actually ran
a ram stress test comparing an m1
macbook
to a windows based intel laptop and
found that the new
unified memory in the m1 chip did
in fact perform more efficiently than
traditional ram and we actually proved
it by running multiple performance tests
and showing how a dell xps laptop would
throttle down performance while having
the ram maxed out as much as we possibly
could
and we found that the m1 macbook barely
took a hit in performance
compared to the xps so yeah the new
unified memory architecture is
definitely one of the reasons why the m1
max
have been performing so well and the
engineers over at
apple know this so they need to make
sure that you
absolutely do not run out of dedicated
unified memory
so that the performance stays quick and
consistent to do that
they swap some of the tasks that don't
require high performance
from the dedicated ram over to the ssd
and what people are worried about is if
the m1 max swap out
much more data than an intel based mac
or any other computer out there
so now that i've explained the whole ssd
swapping issue
let's take a look at if this is
something that you should actually be
worried about
and i'll also get into a couple of
possible solutions
if you are worried and it's something
that's holding you back from purchasing
an m1 mac
first off i downloaded the free trial of
dx drive
and ran it on both of our m1 macbooks
the same ones we've been testing
ever since they were released back in
november and both of them have
absolutely perfect ssds with zero
percent usage
in terms of the lifespan which is great
news i then scoured through a bunch of
forums on the internet
trying to figure out just how many
people are having ssd lifespan
issues with their m1 max and to my
surprise almost
everyone had ssd usage numbers between 0
and 1 which is nowhere near
the numbers that other people were
showing us i then checked a few results
that people posted on reddit
but once again most of them showed zero
percent
ssd lifespan usage so what in the world
could be behind
some people getting three percent usage
or even
10 usage well i did a bit of research
and quite a few people think that this
is actually a software bug
either with mac os itself or with the
smart monitoring tool
that many people use to check their ssd
usage others believe it could actually
be a bug within specific apps
that could be causing this issue like
for example
dan seifert posted some tweets showing
that he had massive ssc swap usage
on his intel-based mac he then found
that it was a bug with a specific
app hand mirror and when he closed it
the huge amount of ssd swapping stopped
so it could actually be
some users having an issue with specific
apps that were bugging out the ssd
but then i dug a little bit deeper this
time focusing on
m1 max and i found a reddit post where
someone found
that rosetta 2 was actually causing a
high amount of swap usage
on his m1 mac this would actually make a
whole lot of sense because rosetta 2
is only found on m1 max and it's used
for translating intel-based apps
into apple silicon supporting apps he
basically said that there were two
chromium-based intel
apps whatsapp and discord that were
translated using rosetta 2
and they were causing the high swap
usage he then
uninstalled both apps and switched to
using the web-based versions of them
and bam the high ssd swapping went away
so he figured that it could be a bug
with rosetta 2
or the chromium-based engines that
aren't optimized yet for apple silicon
and then one user commented on his post
saying that the 150 gigs of write per
day that he was experiencing
prior to uninstalling those apps
actually wasn't too bad
since it would take 14 years of usage at
that rate
for the ssd to fail which is much longer
than anyone would actually be keeping
that m1 mac
so based on the very small amount of
people who actually had high ssd
lifespan usage
and the multiple pieces of evidence of
software bugs causing this
issue i'm gonna bet that this is
completely software related
and there's a chance that apple can fix
this with an update
or perhaps they already did and we just
don't know about it yet
so from the looks of things i would say
that there really isn't anything to be
worried about
based on the very small number of people
that were actually affected
and on top of that the tech report
tested ssd lifespan
and found that they last much longer
than the ratings
like a samsung 840 series ssd which
lasted
over 800 terabytes written and an 840
pro
which was rated for up to 73 terabytes
written
but apparently lasted over two pata
bytes written
which is over 2 000 terabytes so
personally
i don't think anyone should be worried
about this at all
but in the case that you are still
worried there
are a couple of things that you can do
to avoid this issue at all costs
if we take a look at the same sabrand
rocket ssd from earlier in this video
the larger storage models have much
higher terabytes written ratings
so if you're worried about your ssd
wearing out one way to help is to
purchase a larger ssd
for your m1 mac since they last longer
another thing you can do
is order an m1 mac with 16 gigabytes of
ram
since it should technically use less ssd
swapping
due to the larger stored size one user
on reddit returned his eight gigabyte m1
mac
and switched it for a 16 gig ram model
and saw his swap usage go down
significantly
so that's also a great option and
finally there is a way to completely
disable swap
which you can find by googling this
article's title but i don't recommend it
at
all because honestly it's there for a
reason
and apple's engineers would have toned
it down
if it was actually a major issue like
everyone's making it out to be
so there you guys go hopefully you
learned something new and if you're now
confident in buying an n1 mac
i'm going to leave links in the
description below to the best value and
when mac there
is and definitely click the circle about
to subscribe for more videos like this
one
thanks for watching and we'll see you in
the next video
you